public sénat et éco dds vaud présente
pourvu que ça dure
[Musique]
bonjour ravi de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle saison de pourvu que ça dure
les missions qui rend les
co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui focus sur nos futurs
champions de jeunes entreprises au
potentiel immense qui ont vocation à
être les leaders de demain à l'image
d'une secte qui transforme des scarabées
en une farine riche en protéines vous
verrez ces potentiels gens connaissent
un développement fulgurant à l'image du
site du bricolage en ligne mano mano son
président nous expliquera comment il
compte devenir le numéro un en europe
dr lee deezer ou encore blabla car la
france compte une vingtaine de licorne
c'est ainsi qu'on appelle ses jeunes
pousses valoriser plus d'un milliard
d'euros mais lesquels peuvent vraiment
réussir à créer de la richesse et des
emplois réponse est le patron de ge
capital mais d'abord notre reportage sur
cette start up qui m des insectes dans
notre assiette kevin berck
depuis 2013 les entreprises de moins de
10 ans non coté en bourse est valorisée
à plus d'un milliard d'euros sont
baptisés les licornes elles sont issues
pour la plupart des secteurs des
technologies du numérique du web de la
finance ou encore du e-commerce
elles sont trois cents dans le monde
dont une vingtaine en france come back
markets alan mano mano d'octo libre ou
encore blabla car le gouvernement
souhaite atteindre les 25 licorne d'ici
en lice insect une entreprise française
spécialisée dans l'élevage d'insectes et
leur transformation en ingrédients à
destination des animaux domestiques et
d'élevage dans les prochains mois elle
s'attaque à l'alimentation humaine un
nouveau marché qui pourrait lui
permettre d'accéder au cercle très fermé
des big horn
l'idée nous est venue a plutôt par une
recharge de sens ces sept 7 ans via qui
nous a portés à
sur sur l'alimentation ont tombé sur ce
sujet des insectes en général on est
tombé sur le ténébreux par un militaire
en particulier le télé brio molitor le
scarabée pour les intimes insect le
cultive dans des fermes verticales
inspiré des fourmilières le but produire
une farine nutritive plus respectueuse
de l'environnement et ça marche moins de
25% d'eau consommé moins 35 % de co2
émis et une surface agricole 100 fois
moins grande que pour une production de
protéines animales
voilà notre protéines ressemble à ça là
vous enverrez un petit peu donc c'est là
on a la forme poudre de la protéine en
l'occurrence donc c'est notre scarabées
on va d huile est
broyé puis séchés et ça va nous donner
cette tour on peut aussi avoir la
protéine sous forme plus de liquide près
là ça va vraiment dépendre
du client de l'application pendant
longtemps de produits qu'on veut faire
ces protéines peuvent servir d'engrais
pour les plantes et leur apporter un
boost de croissance mais pas seulement
les animaux et leur système immunitaire
aussi en raffolent comme ces chiens qui
se ruent sur leur propre est à base
d'insectes ou ce chat qui en redemande
et c'est bon pour la santé moins de
maladies de peau notamment
on a on a remarqué qu'il avait des
propriétés stimulantes sur les systèmes
immunitaires on a remarqué qu'il y avait
des des propriétés de prise de poids
chez les ch et les poissons par exemple
on a des extrêmement bonnes performances
avec les truites et les commandes sont
au rendez-vous à 6 aujourd'hui à la ddt
plus de 100 millions d'euros contre les
chiffres donnent le vertige et
l'entreprise ne compte pas s'arrêter là
si elle veut poursuivre son hyper
croissance elle doit conquérir un
nouveau marché convaincre les humains de
se nourrir avec des insectes je dis
souvent que il ya 25 ans personne ne
manger de poisson cru parce que c'était
censé faire tomber malade aujourd'hui
manger un sushi c'était un problème donc
les habitudes alimentaires en fête
change très vite et a en tout cas en
france quand c'est bon on y revient
l'entreprise voit grand et embauchent à
tour de bras quatre employés il ya dix
ans ils sont aujourd'hui plus de 200
l'entreprise c'est une vocation
économique c'est une question sociale
sur le social le fait de pouvoir créer
des emplois une occupation sur meetic a
du sens c'est quelque chose de super
chouette et l'équipe ne s'arrête pas là
pour honorer les contrats à venir et
conservé sa place de leader elle se
lance dans la construction de la plus
grande ferme verticale au monde en
picardie et produira plus de 100 tonnes
de protéines d'insectes d'ici la fin de
l'année
[Musique]
mano mano d'octo libre deezer ou encore
blabla car la france compte de plus en
plus de licorne mais tout réussiront
elles à devenir nos champions de demain
bonjour jean schmitt bonjour c'est le
président de jaude capitale c'est vrai
que jamais les startups en france dont
lever autant d'argent 10 milliards
d'euros cette année a priori et c'est
vrai qu'on a souvent regretté que les
apple et facebook
les google ne soit pas allé en france ne
soit pas français mais avec tout cet
argent qui est déversé ce qu'on n'est
pas en train de voir naître sous nos
yeux et clore les champions français de
2030 justement
d'abord c'est exceptionnel on vit à un
moment où il ya une croissance dans
l'investissement qui est qui est énorme
on est encore très en-deça de ce à quoi
on devrait être si on se compare au pib
américain
on est à la moitié de ce qu'on devrait
faire pour financer autant que nos amis
américains leur propre start up donc on
devrait doubler notre investissement
pourrait être à égalité et c'est ce
qu'on a fait sur un an ce qu'on a fait
sur un an ils l'ont fait ils l'ont fait
en six mois et bien rattrapé notre
retard on rattrape d'autres retards et
puis s'il faut espérer c'est que si on
continue sur cette tendance là on va le
dépasser bon insect qu'on a vu un
reportage manome annoncera que le
président juste après 10 heures dr yves
le disait miracle' ovh claire des gens
n'oublient on peut savoir d'ores et déjà
qu'ils sont les pépites qui ont tout
pour être les champions français de
demain alors en tout cas les ingrédients
je pense quand une licorne est un
champion il ya une petite différence
unis quand une société dont certains ont
décidé qu'elle valait 1 milliard oui ça
c'est aujourd'hui s'attaquent
aujourd'hui dans dix ans un champion
c'est autre chose un champion c'est une
société qui va avoir à la fois qui va
changer notre vie qui va apporter des
choses très constructive donc à ses
clients et puis de l'autre côté c'est
une société qui va créer beaucoup de
valeur pour ses actionnaires dans de
biathlon tout c'est licorne quatre
sorcières qui potentiellement seront des
champions en 2030 où on voit des
sociétés qui sont tous dias nantes
d'octo lieb et enthousiasmant c'est 2000
salariés aujourd'hui c'est une
croissance phénoménale et on voit une
société qui part de sa part de marché et
qui commence à aller vers des
technologies de plus en plus
structurantes donc c'est une société qui
est très enthousiasmant anti-insectes
s'est très tôt pour le dire encore mais
elle porte en elle quelque chose de neuf
c'est que elle a des usines pendant très
longtemps lusine c'était un gros mot les
investisseurs ne savent pas investir
dans des usines aujourd'hui et c'est le
début de quelque chose mais les géants
aujourd'hui sont dans la tech donc c'est
heureux qu'on ait peut-être beaucoup de
teck parmi toutes ces dix cordes alors
beaucoup de texte est très important et
je pense que c'est une question de
cheptel on a on a élevé un cheptel de
licorne qui est super intéressant et
très enthousiasmant beaucoup dans des
places de marché beaucoup dans des
services internet je pense qu'il est
très important maintenant qu'on a élevé
des licornes dans le domaine de la
technologie et des ce qu'on appelle deep
tech est ce que nos licorne sont
peut-être de futurs pensionnaires du cac
40 on sait pas c'est trop tôt pour le
sergent suis absolument certain on va
dire j'ai chevauchée unicorn quelques
temps etc des sociétés convoi être
irrésistiblement croissance aéro c'est
une société qui faisait qui a créé dix
mille emplois dans des usines et qui en
même temps est dans la poche de tout le
monde qui fait le module de
reconnaissance faciale des iphone elle
apporte quelque chose aux gens qui est
incontestable est de l'autre côté elle
va créer beaucoup de valeur pour ses
actionnaires le destin d'une licorne
parfois souvent c'est de se faire
racheter par un grand groupe c'est
regrettable comme comme destinée ou non
c'est normal c'est normal c'est celle
qui peuvent devenir des grands groupes
vont tenter l'expérience et je crois que
l'investissement qu'on fait maintenant
qui bien plus important qu'avant les
mène à ne plus être des proies la proie
c'est presque une fabrication de trois
qu'on faisait avant on faisait on
investissait dans les sociétés qui ne
devait faire qu'une seule chose on
finançait ça et on vendait le projet
aujourd'hui avec des financements de 100
200 300 millions de dollars dans des
sociétés leur permet de devenir des
vrais entreprises alors jean schmitt la
france enregistre aujourd'hui une
vingtaine de licorne s'est dit pour soit
en gros des licornes européenne qu'est
ce qu'on vient on crie cocorico et
comment se situe par rapport à pour le
coin nos voisins européens c'est pas
fantastique si je reprends le pib la
france en europe si je me trompe pas
c'est 20 % du pib européen
bah on doit faire au minimum 20% des ddd
l'histoire de vos des blés le nombre de
faux n'oubliant de savoir que l'objectif
du président c'est 25 en 2025 licorne
c'est très bien de fixer nyala mais on y
est on y est et je pense que c'est bien
de fixer un objectif c'est bien d'avoir
un président qui s'intéressent à ça et
je pense que cet objectif il est là pour
être largement dépassé est ce que ces
futurs champions seront ou pas
pourvoyeur d'emplois dans nos bassins
dans nos régions est-ce que c'est
licorne vont porter la création
d'emplois encore une fois en france
sachant que tout est en jeunes ont des
structures de coûts qui sont plutôt
basses
ça dépend lesquels je dirais que prenez
veepee par exemple qui est une nicole
maintenant on est tous d'accord sur le
sujet c'est 7000 salariés et 3500 en
france donc elles sont créatrices
d'emplois directs et indirects bien sûr
si on va en plus dans la direction des
licornes et qui vont créer des usines et
des qui vont créer de l'industrie là on
crée beaucoup d'emplois en revanche
c'est vrai que les licornes qui créent
des emplois précaires ou qui créent des
emplois en qui sont en marge de la loi
je pense à des délits cordenons
française comme comme hubert ou d'autres
s'expliquant ne l'a très peu de valeur
effectivement et c'est pas celles qui
sont souhaitables de données pour le
coup bien valorisé malgré tout oui parce
qu'elle crée le vous savez elle crée
beaucoup de valeur pour les actionnaires
ces entreprises mais comme on le disait
licorne champions je peux pas considérer
qu'à aucun moment où l'hiver est un
champion de quoi que ce soit bon
puisqu'on parle de valorisation à ce que
ces problématiques ou pas qu'on valorise
ses licorne 1 milliard d'euros ou plus
pour des boîtes qui pas toutes mais
certaines pertes de l'argent est ce que
c'est un raisonnement à courte vue que
de dire ça comme ça parce qu'on voit
comme des valorisations qui atteignent
des niveaux
exubérant ou stratosphérique extravagant
diront certains je crois qu'il faut
expliquer ce que ça veut dire ce
milliard un milliard c'est beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent
on n'est ni quand on dépasse un million
de base de valorisation qu'est ce que ça
veut dire personne ne l'a ce milliard ce
milliard il est il est quelque part en
l'air on a décrété que ça valait 1
milliard mais personne n'a touché ce
milliard je crois que c'est important de
le dire il ya un investisseur qui a
décidé d'investir 100 millions dans
cette société parce qu'elle a besoin de
100 millions pour se développer se
développer et puis il allait trouver une
valorisation je vais prendre 10% de
cette société parce que en dessous de
10% ça vaut pas le coup de travailler au
dessus de 10% c'est l'entreprise qui va
pas être d'accord et la valorisation
personnes décider ou décréter que c'est
un milliard elle en est une conséquence
de ce calcul est donc c'est le
conséquence de je veux tant dans une
société pourtant alors est ce que c'est
pour autant extravagants ben non
tout le monde fait pareil dans tous les
pays tout le monde fait pareil mais
franco français et j'ai envie de dire
c'est à après tout ce après deux trois
ans qu'on verra si c'est extravagant
quand quelqu'un décidera de vraiment
cette fois-ci acheté la société pour
plusieurs milliards ou quand elle
rentrera en bourse et que là pour le
coup elle vaudra plusieurs milliards et
ça sera valorisé non pas par un
investisseur un petit groupe
d'investisseurs mais par un marché
certains disent que cette flambée du
nombre de deux start-up de licorne en
france et même ailleurs c'est la
contrepartie de cet argent pas cher les
taux d'intérêt qui sont bas et donc tout
cet argent frais qui a besoin c'est
investir qui pousse à la hausse est les
cours des entreprises absolument c'est
une excellente nouvelle qui est tant
d'argent disponible parce que enfin on a
de l'argent qui permet de créer des
emplois créés les nouvelles entreprises
la nouvelle allocation télé peut-être
parfois sont ces cartes de la réalité
économique oui il faut il faut éviter un
1 traverse et prendre la grosse tête
certes il ya quelquefois chacun veut son
milliards dans son portefeuille et si
tout le monde veut une licorne
évidemment on va avoir un petit problème
en cause n'est pas déjà le cas aux jo je
pense qu'il y avait des excès à
l'évidence quand on voit des sociétés
qui font quelques centaines de milliers
de chevaux d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
équivalent 1 milliard on se pose des
questions
maintenant quand on prend des exemples
comme dr lee boylan qui sont une société
qui fait déjà 100 millions et qu'il ya
des trajectoires de croissance
extrêmement rapide
non on n'est pas particulièrement choqué
alors il faut pas qu'on considère qu
investir beaucoup d'argent à créer une
assurance sur le fait qu'on tienne
l'objectif face à reims une erreur oui
ça serait ça serait facile de créer de
l'argent à la quantité de talents qui
est nécessaire pour faire une société
reste le même simplement cet argent
permet de le faire plus vite elle et
merci beaucoup merci j'en suis le
président de jal capital merci beaucoup
merci voilà justement on va demander aux
patrons de mano mano comment il compte
s'y prendre pour devenir le leader
européen du bricolage en ligne
[Musique]
quelle ascension en 18 mois mano mano
c'est désormais plus de 50 millions de
visiteurs par mois un succès qui fait de
l'ombre grand acteur du bricolage
bonjour christian elles sont pour david
stich à cadrer installez-vous à 6 à 3 c
est le président et cofondateur de mano
mano les confinements répétition vous
ont quand même beaucoup aidé parce que
ça a donné l'envi voire l'obligation à
beaucoup de français d'améliorer leur
chez eux leur intérieur résultat vos
ventes ont été multipliées par 4 l'an
dernier en 2020 est ce que sont la crise
sanitaire jeudi manière un peu abrupte à
ce que sont en crise sanitaire vous ne
seriez pas là aujourd'hui en tout cas
pas aussi vite
sûrement petite explication le ventre on
l'étudié par deux à près de 800 se
chiffre à 4 047 une idée une épique
mensuel ou là pour le coup on a eu des
fois 80 surtout les premiers confinement
à partir de ce mois d'avril oui donc
c'est vrai les français et même au
niveau européen se retrouver chez eux
les en profiter pour bé s'occuper de
leur intérieur donc c'est vrai que ça
nous aurait bien bien pousser oui si on
achète surtout et pas seulement des pots
de peinture et des pinceaux sur mano
mano et puis des questions subsidiaires
est ce que vous vous souciez du
recyclage est justement des pots de
peinture on est pourvu que ça dure des
missions qui rend les co-responsables
tout est présent raison on est on est en
plein dedans
ce qu'on dit souvent chez madame non
c'est que
petit volume d'affaires +10 cette
comptabilité gros volume d'affaires
grosse rentabilité de cossette un
chantier nous conte à ouvrir depuis deux
ans chez nous on communique pas dessus
donc je nous ai rien dit pour l'instant
mais c'est sûr que c'est au coeur d'une
stratégie il est client vous attendre là
dessus où ils viennent surtout pour
avoir des prix à des prix moins chers et
d'ailleurs c'est tout temps le cas on a
tout le temps prix moins cher et on se
dit que c'est aussi la contrepartie le
fait de ne pas avoir peut-être de
conseils personnalisés conclu par un
magasin prischois conseil ses triptyques
qu'on avait au départ avec fils de
champville donc le cofondateur prischois
conseil c'est toujours aujourd'hui notre
politique le prix oui on essaie d'être
un taxi parce que vos données sur le web
si on n'a pas le prix ont fait rien le
choix aujourd'hui on a près de dix
millions de produits quand vous comparez
pas les grandes surfaces de bricolage ou
pouvant trouver entre 50 mille neuf cent
mille sur amazon sur votre juste par
amazon c'est plus sûrement virement
beaucoup je ne sais pas du tout je ne
sais pas combien de produits ils ont
sûrement ils ont attaqué sept verticale
en même temps que nous mais comparé une
recherche sur ces
c'est acteur généraliste je parle pas
que de cet américain la médée aux gros
acteur généraliste vous faites une
recherche de bricolage qui est très
spécialisés et faites à une chaîne
rivale on verra vraiment la différence
ou encore des rédacteurs spécialistes
face à vous ou un acteur généralement en
termes de choix locaux ça j'aurai une
question pour le conseil l'avenir qui a
du conseil mais c'est structurant le
conseil vous êtes sûrement un grand
bricoleur succède à vis des examens
gauche quand vous entrez dans un magasin
n'est pas juste que vous faites et vous
cherchez quelqu'un pour vous aider sauf
qu'il ya gérant il ya personne ou alors
la personne est en pause clope ou fait
autre chose donc c'est très compliqué
chez nous on a industrialisé ce conseil
là c'était un conseil qui se fait soit
par 'achat' donc automatiquement pour
être sur une catégorie ou rester un
petit peu de temps sur quelque chose
donc on sent que vous êtes à la
recherche de quelque chose d'autre donc
du conseil shaddai un robot elle de lui
avec de l'humain que d'humains êtes sur
un taux de croissance donc de 100% dans
les langues est sûr que là
on a eu vraiment ce fois de la dernière
aujourd'hui et heureusement les
européens font autre chose que rester à
la maison ils peuvent partir seront
partis en vacances ils sont partis faire
la fête ont retrouvé leur famille comme
comme tout le monde et bien sûr donc ils
ont un peu un peu vous conserver des
taux de croissance proche de 50 % à 2
chiffres parce que c'est ça le destin
d'une licorne aussi c'est d'avoir un
développement fulgurant je sais pas si
c'est lié à la licorne
c'est plutôt lié à ce qu'on attendait 3
ans c'est ce qu'on attendait bien sûr vu
les niveaux de valorisation et on en
parlera après
donc je sais pas si c'est lié à ce
statut licorne moi j'ai jamais vue de
les corriger parce que c'est donc vous
voyez c'est ça que licorne mais bien sûr
on ne comprenait pas pourquoi on appelle
ça comme ça
n'ont mis au jour de ma vie je sais pas
mais c'est un vocabulaire qui est avant
tout je pense journalistique ou c'est du
marketing c'est de vendre quelque chose
pourquoi même mais on n'est pas avec
philips est vraiment pas l'objectif
d'atteindre ce ce statut qui n'est pas
au final moi je suis content parce que
je crée des emplois je suis entreprises
françaises ont fait ce sont deux
profonde indignation en france on a
créer 800 emplois en france
on va en créer mille encore en france et
notre offre est avant tout français donc
là on est une boîte française on paye
nos impôts en france non pas en belgique
ou en suisse ou au luxembourg
aujourd'hui donc on est solidaires suite
en france c'est le premier pays qu'on
est au vert en 2013 dont vous
autoproclamé premier en france où il ya
des gens pour le coup il a fait les
benchmark avec les gros acteurs
américains et autres donc le oui non non
on a fait les belles toi qu'on a vu
qu'on était donc bien bien leader online
des ventes de produits de l'ag de la
ligue m'assurer en tant que c'est une
place de marché faut expliquer dans une
classe de marché de marques et place du
bricolage vous n'achetez pas vous ne
produisez pas vous ne verrez pas les
stocks en fait vous mettez en relation
un vendeur et un acheteur quelque part
ça ça et vous tournez au passage une
commission sur chaque transaction c'est
ça le biz le coeur du business oui le
mano à mano avec un petit peu plus de
complexité on a inventé une espèce de
nouveaux modèles marketplace on n'a pas
des millions de vendeurs on n'a que des
milliers de vendeurs on est avant tout
une offre locale puisque on va chercher
en fait vrai le tri dans les vendeurs
qui viennent chez nous les fournisseurs
ils sont ils sont triés sur le volet
exactement pourquoi vous accepter un et
pas un autre sur quel le prix critères
le prix et le choix on se targue de la
qualité des produits aussi exactement cc
c'est vraiment le choix et la qualité ce
n'est pas ça le coffre quand on parle de
choix le cadre du fonds donc on essaie
de prendre les vendeurs qui qu'ils
soient efficaces et ils sont bien placés
dans l'eau sur le marché pour ne pas
avoir inondé d'offres inutiles entre
guillemets pour le client donc il ya un
vrai travail de sélection au démarrage
est ce que mano mano a vocation à
remplacer à terme les leroy merlin et
castorama les bricorama ou pas parce que
si c'est avec l adema du monde au
chômage
encore une fois on a créé 800 fois on va
en créer 8000 cette année donc bon je
sais pas ce que c'est parce que munich
en il ya combien de temps on est ravi
dans l'industrie physiques dans les
magasins notre vocation c'est pas
détruire ou détrôné une vocation c'est
de sur un marché où il ne se passe rien
ou peu d'innovation depuis un
demi-siècle d'offrir autre chose aux
clients européens c'est ça notre
vocation je n'aime pas le mot disrupt
aimé apporter une offre qui n'existait
pas sur sur le sur le net et la porte et
enfin aux clients pourront pour qu'ils
puissent n'ont pas trouvé que des
bouquins ou des deux offres culturelles
mais qui puisse vous il bricolait et
donc avoir une démocratie sur les prix
sur le choix et c'est donc c'est ça
notre ambition est ce que vous ne
redoutez pas fait son récent que en
mettant le paquet sur le digital les les
distributeurs vous rattrape et peut-être
vous empêche de grandir aujourd'hui ils
jouent tous au marketplace ils ont ils
ont vu que le modèle fonctionne et donc
il faut il s'engouffre dans la brèche
pourquoi pas avec grand plaisir ce qui
est important c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ne
travaille pas qu'avec des revendeurs ou
d'intermédiaires on va directement vers
l'industriel donc on a des enfants on
fait le même métier quasiment dans le
sens qu'on va chercher des offres qui
viennent directement de des actions
nouvelles ou des ppg qui sont donc des
producteurs de peinture vous prenez vous
prendra donc pas directement la haie et
ont compris que une partie de leur
avenir c'est être passé sur le digital
ce que leur offre pas aujourd'hui ou
correctement l lsquo appel et goran les
grandes surfaces de bricolage un petit
mot de la valorisation quand même il
faut en parler de mano mano en dessous
des 3 milliards d'euros c'est une des
plus grosses licorne en tout cas
aujourd'hui en france vous en pensez
quoi en terme de valorisation c
c'est pas votre sujet ou s'est justifié
il faudra des livres et la performance
keira derrière évidemment que c'est pas
un peu excessif quand on sait que
l'argent des investisseurs aujourd'hui
coule à flot et intérêts sont bas et
donc parfois ça peut les pousser les
investisseurs à surpayer pour être un
ticket dans une boîte est donc ça fait
augmenter la valorisation même
c'est le fait la demande c'est sûr que
plus seulement que la demande allait la
salle mandela c'est sûr que ça donc ça
répond à une
offre également
ça met aussi la pression bien sûr c'est
sûr que quand on est tout petit vous un
peu moins de pression aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup plus de pression je dirais que
cette serre vraiment 2 milliards 6 juin
de manière je ne sais pas je sais pas
combien qu'un savon moi ça moi je juge
je vois plutôt à l'aune de nous ne
devons pas qu'on concret en france c'est
plutôt ça mon
de plus utilisés d'ici fin 2022
exactement il ya tellement de choses à
faire lance donc dans ce marché qui
étaient tous des alizés que c'est de
faire du motif que tout va devenir un
grand champion français et européens
parce que c'est ça l'objectif voilà
merci d'arrêter avec nos christian
reiser président cofondateur de man o
man au volant par maintenant des lycans
de demain d'autant qu'en france on est
servi beaucoup des pépites qui sont
prometteuses
[Musique]
donner une seconde vie à notre peau pour
faire avancer la recherche voilà
l'ambition de génos qui n'est entreprise
basée à toulouse qui pourrait faire
partie de nos futurs licorne bonjour
emilie nos jours d'avis alors j'ai aussi
des lauréates du program scale up
excellence oui c'est un dispositif qui
est porté par la french tech et qui a
pour vocation de repérer les jeunes
pousses les plus prometteuses l'idée
bien sûr c'est de leur donner un coup
d'accélérateur notamment à
l'international alors cette année 63
entreprises sont lauréates parmi elles
vous l'avez dit genoscreen qui propose
une alternative au test sur les animaux
grâce à des échantillons de peau humaine
alors c'est quoi ces échantillons de
peau alors il s'agit de restes
chirurgicaux qui nous viennent pour
l'essentiel d'opérations d'abdos
plastique alors l'abdo plastique pour
rappel c'est quand on retire des excès
de peau sur des personnes qui ont perdu
beaucoup de kilos et dont la peau du
ventre s'est détendu en général ces
tissus ils sont incinérés avec les
autres déchets chez régis coste qui vous
m'accorderez n'est pas très écolo et
justement génos qu'il ait bien eu l'idée
de récupérer ces déchets humains afin de
les recycler en quelque sorte pour le
bien de la recherche que deviennent ces
échantillons de peau pour le cool alors
ils vont pouvoir être maintenue en vie
pendant sept jours grâce à un gène qui
va aller nourrir et empêcher la fuite
des défenses immunitaires cette
journaliste c'est colossal ça laisse le
temps aux chercheurs et bien de réaliser
beaucoup d'expérience et donc de se
passer de tests sur les animaux mais est
ce qu'ils sont c'est est mis aussi
efficaces que ceux pratiqués par don sur
les animaux achetons ils sont beaucoup
plus efficaces là toute la ligne
d'ailleurs des tests sur les animaux
parce que les animaux n'ont pas la même
structure que nous n'ont pas les mêmes
défenses immunitaires ni le même
métabolisme d'ailleurs le taux d'échec
est de 95% général on ne récupère que 5%
de ces données animales donc si engendre
évidemment beaucoup de tâtonnements de
temps et d'argent perdu et c'est ce qui
explique aussi et bien qu' il faut à peu
près dix ans en moyenne pour fabriquer
un médicament donc on voit une vie la
limite des tests sur sur les animaux
mais en quoi c'est tout petit bouton il
serait plus fiable pour le coup c'est
vrai qu'on a qu'un tout petit morceau
mais il contient en fait une masse
phénoménale de type de cellules
différentes et donc d'information
finalement la peau c'est un petit peu
comme une fenêtre sur l'être humain
d'ailleurs c'est le plus grand organe de
notre corps dont vous imaginez
finalement le gain de temps et d'argent
et puis toutes les promesses bien sûr
pour la recherche est ce que ces tests
vont concerner uniquement les
problématiques pour le coulis enfin
qu'au départ la société c'était vraiment
spécialisé dans les problèmes de peau
notamment pour l'industrie dermato
cosmétiques mais depuis elle s'est
diversifiée avec une collaboration que
des grands noms de l'industrie
pharmaceutique alors comme ça nous
filles comme astrazeneca ou gsk alors
aujourd'hui des labos du monde entier
viennent la voir pour travailler avec
elle notamment sur l'immunologie sa
grande spécialité mais également sur la
manière de notre corps réagit face aux
injections de médicaments et de vaccins
justement les vaccins à ce que cette
société a un vrai au développement des
vaccins anti copie oui alors justement
elle a participé à la l'émergence en un
temps record vous le savez de la rn
messager elle a d'ailleurs été la seule
plateforme capable de tester ces vaccins
sur des échantillons humains donc c'est
vrai que la pandémie a été vraiment un
tremplin pour elle qui va sans doute lui
permet d'aller beaucoup plus haut est-ce
qu'on est entré mis dans une dans une
nouvelle ère ça veut dire qu'on va
pouvoir bientôt se passer des tests sur
les animaux avec c'est assez inédit pour
la première fois des chercheurs ont
accès à des données humaines et non plus
seulement animal est évidemment d'un
point de vue éthique le progrès est
immense on va enfin arrêter de faire
souffrir les animaux pour le bien de la
science d'ailleurs je précise que depuis
93 en europe ces tests sont interdits
dans tout ce qui est industrie
cosmétique alors à quand pour
l'industrie pharmaceutique et bien selon
genoscreen dans moins de 20 ans il n'y
aura plus aucun animal qui servira de
cobaye merci militaire sida les allées
voit la preuve que ça dure les missions
qui rend les co-responsables c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui j'espère que ça vous a
plu magazine à voir ou à revoir sur
public sénat et en replay sur
publicsenat.fr rendez vous dans deux
semaines
[Musique]
c'était pourvu que ça dure avec le
soutien décoder ds